all right so our
next
speaker
is a legend
he has
a number of really big packages up on
crayon
whether it's carrot or tidy models or so
much stuff he's been working on r for
what seems like forever
um
i don't mind uh tooting his horn too
much because you know he's an awesome
guy
he spoke at the first ever nyr the first
ever dcr he's spoken at many nyrs he's
spoken at the meetup he's done workshops
both you know summertime workshops and
conference workshops he's been around
forever
but perhaps most importantly out of all
of his accomplishments this past year
instead of working on a sourdough
starter like everybody else he spent his
time perfecting a durian creme brulee
please welcome max
uh thanks for coming um
my talk
is about the pandemic and unlike
everybody who's like hey i have the best
data analysis for coveted
infection rates and things like that i
want to talk about something different
about how i've had this great data set
uh that i've used for training and
documentation and testing
and it kind of got borked by the uh
pandemic and the grand scheme of things
this is the least of anybody's problem
so it's not that big of a deal
relatively speaking but for me i had to
figure out a way to
mitigate the pandemic issues
so this is what i'm going to talk about
um
right so let's look at the data
so you know here's
what happened before you know we we saw
basically increasing ridership
um
over time i think around like 2016 and
maybe or 2015 it may be plateaued out
and you know
2019 seem to be dipping down a little
bit so that was a little bit interesting
but not as interesting as now
so you know this is
pretty much expected ridership dropped
um and then you see like a slow increase
so um
you know that's now and this is like
really like what i consider to be
the the data that i'm going to call like
the coveted data so i'll use the phrase
like pre pandemic which is everything to
the left of april 1st
by that dotted line and everything to
the right would be what i'll call the
code data and then you can see
you know on the previous slide which i'm
afraid to go back to
you see these precipitous drops those
are the holidays
and things like that so you know we
haven't really
we haven't really gone through that as
much here but i don't think the same
data patterns are manifesting in the
cove data as they were in the original
data
at least not yet
so that's the situation and the the
thought is well you know what we do
about this
um you know i'm thinking about this like
i feel like well this is probably a
problem that other people are dealing
with and then uh davis vaughn who works
for me uh you know added me on this
tweet basically every time series data
set ever now that we're gonna have to
live with so i'm sure this will spawn
many many dissertations uh in papers but
um i thought i'd take a shot at seeing
like some ways we might be able to
mitigate the effect of this this drop in
potential recovery in fact this data set
i'd rather have because it recovers
fairly quickly compared to the train
data
so you know i see there's like really
two problems here i mean the obvious one
is that the the patterns in the data are
completely different
um
so you know how much the previous data
the pre-pandemic data
really is applicable now is kind of in
question
another thing is a little more subtle
and that's a change of scale so before
we were getting like you know ridership
and like the 15 thousands and now it's
like
in the low thousands and so you know
what we can do is we could
try to use different data sets to
predict the current data but if we were
to compare a rooming square
mean squared error that we get now
compared to what we had pre-pandemic you
know we might still come up with an
armacy of like two or one or something
like that which seems in the the range
of what we're getting before but it's
really not the same thing they're in the
same units
but since the scale is so drastically
changed i'm not sure that comparing uh
values we get now to previous years uh
pharmacies like pre-pandemic armacies
are really applicable in fact in the
previous year since the scale was so
much larger some of the residuals that
we would get from a fairly good model
were bigger
than the actual ridership numbers that
we're getting now so they really feel
like apples and oranges to go back and
forth so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to compare different approaches
and evaluate them with different um
parts of the current code data and so
and since i don't know that we can
really compare arma cs all that well i'm
going to uh show some visual
representations of the fit especially
for the test set so just to give us it's
more subjective but it'll give us a good
sense of like what's going on with the
data
so i was saying about how to approach
this
here the four things i came up with the
first one is like yeah business as usual
it's machine learning let the machine
figure it out and you know what could go
wrong um i'm this is like the antithesis
of every
feeling i have about machine learning uh
but you know it's worth trying out that
you know machines can pick up uh
patterns pretty well what they do
whether they're really there or not and
then maybe if we just you know kept
going like we did before
it might be smart enough to do the right
thing
in a predictable way
the other obvious sort of alternative is
just use the covet data you are kind of
starting fresh we're not seeing the same
patterns as we did before so
you know why use the previous data and
so um
in this particular case what i'll do is
i'll use the data from april 1st 2020
and on
and not do really anything different in
terms of data analysis
now a third approach would be
uh interactions or like a change point
analysis so what i can do is i can look
back and it's actually surprisingly hard
to get actual dates from illinois
government websites but look at
particular times where we think there
might be a shift in ridership where for
example people were first getting
vaccinated or when they start
vaccinating kids between 12 and 15 and
so on and so what i can do is i can put
indicators in the model for that and
then use interactions with those
indicators with the original predictors
to potentially be able to model the
different sort of phases of the pandemic
at least in terms of like vaccination
and things like that and this if you
were fitting a linear model with these
septic terms it would be like a change
point model or a segmented regression
model where you can imagine having like
a period of time that is defined by two
of the indicators and you would from the
interactions been able to be able to
have like a different slope during those
periods so that um
uh might be an approach that would uh
have merit and then the final thing
would be to use case weights is let's
use all the data
but let's give much much more weight to
the curved data than the pre-pandemic
data so what i did is um i took the
pre-pandemic data and gave it like a
case weight of 0.1
and then gave the the cova data case
weight of one which translates to like
each model gives tenfold more emphasis
to the current data than it does to the
previous
data product and pandemic so those are
the four
approaches i'll use
in terms of the models what i'm going to
do is i'm going to resample them and
also hold out the last two weeks as a
test set and so in the resampling i use
rolling forecast origin which is a
resampling method that basically takes a
chunk of data and then uses the next two
weeks to make predictions and computer
pharmacy on that so what we'll have is
with like a rolling rmse
um
from resampling over the period of the
covet data so we'll compare sort of
apples to apples looking at these models
just at the covered data in terms of how
they perform
now there's much more data in the
pre-pandemic so when we look at how many
rmses we might be comparing or how many
like um phases of data we have uh
there's about a thousand weeks in the
pre-pandemic data and only 25 in the
covet data and so um so you know you
would think there would be much more
uncertainty or difficulty mod difficulty
in modeling the cova data because it's
much much smaller
the two models i'm going to use are two
that i know work pretty well for the
model these pre-pandemic cubis is a rule
based uh ensemble method that's very
powerful
um think of it as like xgboost but
better
that'll stir some twitter comments up
and um
and you know that's capable of finding
patterns that may or may not exist in
the data um it's very powerful and
flexible uh the other approach i'll use
is much
more simple which is a glimnet linear
regression um glim that does
regularization so i'll use like a lasso
and weight decay penalty to potentially
regularize the model um the nice thing
about glimnet is it's less prone to
overfitting
so um and it does again fairly well with
these data so these two approaches are
the ones i'm going to take
i'll tune them both about the same
amount and then
you'll see in a little bit i'll use them
for prediction to see how different
models work
now for the interaction approach
what i'm going to do or for all the
models i'll use the database features in
the lag 14 features and then for the
interactions and the code there you see
some um some dates which you know these
are rough dates based on what i could
find from
the government website you know like
there's interaction for when second
doses were occurring around uh uh
january 8th
um you know it's approved for kids
around um april 10th and so these are
the six change points that i could come
up with and then these will be used in
terms of interactions
now on the first slide there is a link
to a github repo with both the slides
and all the code
and a tweet should have gone out about
seven minutes ago
uh that that also gives you the um the
uh
repo name so if you want to look at any
of the details of this uh please do
so here's the resampling results so what
i have is rose or cubist the bottom row
is glimnet and then the columns are
different approaches so if we look at
all using everything
um the data is a little bit variable for
cubists there are some days or some
phases like two-week periods where it
does well and others where it doesn't so
if you look at each particular dot
that's connected on that line that's an
arma c for a particular two week hold
out that again rolls as over time and so
you can see it starts getting better and
better and then the last two is where it
goes off the rails
um clemnet does okay but at least it's
stable so it's slowly decreasing but the
rmc isn't spectacular
um so you know all data
not so great
um when we look at kova data only will
you see a much much better improvement
in both models
they're much more stable
and
you know this seems like a good approach
the interaction model interestingly
is not all that different in results
from the
from the approach where we use all the
data
um
cubist has the ability to find
interactions really easily so if it
would have wanted those interactions it
would have probably used them already so
you don't really see a very different
pattern
um with the interaction approach than
all data it's a little bit better but
not much and interesting also um is that
glimnet just filtered out it eliminated
from the lasso penalty all the
interaction effects so at least glenn
that didn't think they were that
important um to model and i should say i
had a little bit of trouble tuning the
glimmer models here um typically the the
largest penalty i'll usually use is like
point one or one in terms of the amount
of regularization and that did really
badly i was getting really bad negative
predictions
like off by like thousands of rides
which i'd never seen this data so i
bumped up the amount of regularization
and found um you know a good spot where
i was getting good performance and
reasonable numbers but the penalties are
around five or ten depending on the
model it's somewhat unusual but not
unheard of
and the effect of that regularization is
like getting rid of some terms like the
interactions that i thought you know may
have had merit in the model but clearly
you know if they had merit they would
have been retained uh during the feature
selection process
and then finally the case weight
approach
did well for clemnet
cubists
it actually seemed to make things a
little bit worse uh the instability and
performance over time
was not great and you know it had the
worst rmse during a phase
so you know that's not great so it did
help glennette didn't really help cubist
all that much
so that's the resampling over time
i think the main takeaway is that
from these results is that the kova data
only seems to work well
but for the other approaches how well
something worked or not really depends
on what week it is so it may be too too
early to tell
like how these um strategies
will um
will work over time
so next we'll look at the test set data
so here instead of showing you rmc
values what i'm going to do is show you
the actual two weeks of data and so um
so on the y-axis here we have the actual
ridership numbers and their original
units and then you can see the actual
fits for cubist and glimnet so we use
all data
not great
cubist does fairly well except for one
data point at the end is really off on a
monday
um
and then glenn net seemed to be off like
during the week so for this particular
data uh range all data
not my best you know not my best effort
there
for covid we seem to do best in
resampling blimnett's on it cubists like
swung and missed um like during the
second week um it's really over
predicting the um the ridership during
the week
for the interaction models again they're
both really not all that spectacular
again glemnet over predicts on the the
last monday
glimnet is over predicting during the
week so you know not great
and then the case weights for both
models seem to be spot on so despite
cube is not doing well in the case
weights and the previous uh two week
hold outs
um you know this is what we get on the
the current data set the current last
two weeks and it looks pretty great so
that was good um glennette's also um on
on the mark here with k suites so um so
you know if i had to pick many of these
approaches i think right now i'd take
glimnet for both the code only data or
the case weight model
so you know
our conference right you know field by
just show a little bit of our code
you'll find this in the github repo
basically we used unexpectedly tiny
models for this
and uh if we do a group i on the model
the methods and then compute the rmse
and rank them
uh for the test set what we see is the
the articy we get for the case weights
is about 0.5
for coba data is you know about 0.6 and
then cuba's case weights comes in at
about 0.7
again these numbers are much much much
better than i would have gotten
pre-pandemic but again even though
they're in the same units the scale is
so different that i don't think
you know a armisticy of like 1.8 or two
really would have been um
relevant
uh in this particular case
so
so conclusions are
that um the resampling results indicate
that really the best strategy is sort of
up in the air um you know again the code
data only seems to be overall the best
case
but you know we don't know how that's
going to change from week to week so it
might be too early to tell in terms of
making like overall strategy or model
assessments you know i would say that
you know fitting a
high bias model like glimnet which
doesn't have a lot of room to over
interpret the data might be the best
approach whether it's glimnet or
something else so i feel like maybe that
the current amount of data and the
current instability in the code data
really for me sort of makes me think
that a model
that is a little bit um attenuated in
terms of the patterns it could pick up
would be a good idea something that's
pretty simple in other words would be
maybe the best result now
um you know and that's you know the
regularizing aggression is really
appealing because you know it slopes and
intercepts it does uh feature selection
i mean cubis does feature section two
but it's a pretty simple model
i am a little bit concerned about the
amount of um
penalty that was required to fit these
models so maybe over time that will
change but if i had to pick something
now it would probably be a linear model
on the code data only
and then you know these are two models
they behave really differently you know
maybe
some other
non-tree based ensembles besides cubist
would work well
um maybe others wouldn't
and maybe try something like mars that's
in between like machine learning and
linear models
for these data
most of the trends are linear in the
data set so something that's linearish
might be a good choice
to pick
so just want to say thanks for the
invitation speak thanks to teddy model
team which is davis julia and hannah
and alice hill has been great on helping
us make these um excellent looking
uh sharing and slides
so thanks
thank you max i am waiting for you to
add gams to tidy models therefore you
can have your sort of linear experience
so as soon as you add gams to tidy
models and parsnip i think this will all
be solved or at least close enough
max is talking but he doesn't i can't
hear him but he's backstage talking i
can't hear him come back on stage max
oh sorry okay
they were admin last release of parsnip
oh wonderful i'm behind the times thank
you max solving my issues before i even
asked for it and based on um asthma's uh
um presentation yesterday last night i
added bart too but that's still in a pr
so i saw her she just tweeted that
actually just a little bit ago
this is and we just had a number of
causal inference talks i think that's
causal she talked about then you
wouldn't did it yeah or as dan chen said
it's a conference driven development
that's how we do it yeah yep cool thank
you so much for everything
and then we had a few people claiming
complaining about glimnet um we don't
like the name glimnet uh we want glmnet
forever right folks um i said in the
chat you know my heart sank when trevor
hasty told me that it was pronounced
clemnet i'm like why i know what i think
it has to do with sass because they have
like prop glim so i think he was naming
it based off of sas i'm like but we're
not in sas we're an r make it glm net
but it is glennette sadly what can you
do
so our
next speaker